MAASTRICHT, HOLLAND,
WHERE APPARENTLY,
CARS PARK THEMSELVES.
Linsell: SWEET CAR,
BUT WHERE'S THE DRIVER?
Parker: WE'VE SEEN DRIVERLESS
CARS BEFORE
AND THEY'RE NORMALLY PACKED
WITH WIRES AND ELECTRONICS.
BUT IN THIS CASE,
WE CAN'T SEE ANY CONTROLS
AND IT'S DOING DOUGHNUTS.
Narrator:
CREATED BY BJORN HARMS,
HE CLAIMS HE'S CONTROLLING
THIS FULL-SIZE MUSCLE CAR
USING JUST AN RC CONTROLLER.
IT WORKS!
I JUST DON'T GET
HOW HE'S DOING IT.
I CAN'T SEE ANY MOTORS
OR CONTROLS.
Wrigglesworth:
THIS LOOKS REALLY ADVANCED.
Ruben: I LOVE THIS CLIP.
I DON'T CARE
IF IT'S REAL OR FAKE.
DON'T EVEN TELL ME.
Narrator:
WE WENT TO HOLLAND TO FIND OUT
IF THIS CAR REALLY IS
BEING CONTROLLED REMOTELY.
I THINK IT'S REAL.
Kundu: I'M NOT REMOTELY
CONVINCED BY THIS.
Narrator:
TELL US, BJORN, IS THIS REALLY
A REMOTE-CONTROLLED CAR,
OR IS THIS V8 A FAKE?
Bjorn: THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT THINK THAT IT'S FAKE.
IT REALLY ISN'T.
IT'S AN RC CAR
WITH 404 HORSEPOWER.
IS THIS CRAZY?
DEFINITELY.
THIS IS EPIC.
WOO-HOO! THIS IS RAD!
Narrator: YEAH,
WE THINK SO TOO.
BUT HOW IS THIS CORVETTE
CONTROLLED?
BJORN HAD A DREAM OF BUILDING
A FULL-SIZED REMOTE-CONTROL CAR.
SO HE TOOK HIS OWN SPORTS CAR
AND MODIFIED IT
SO IT CAN BE DRIVEN
REMOTELY AND MANUALLY.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MY RC CAR
AND OTHER CARS THAT ARE ALSO
RC-CONTROLLED
IS THAT I BUILT ALL THE SERVOS,
ALL THE MOTORS
INSIDE THE DASHBOARD,
AND ON THE CONTROLS
SO THAT THE INTERIOR
LOOKS COMPLETELY STOCK.
Arney: I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS
GUY'S DONE IT ALL BY HIMSELF.
IT LOOKS SEAMLESS.
North: BJORN HAS A RADIO
CONTROLLER IN HIS HANDS
THAT SENDS RADIO WAVES
TO A RECEIVER IN THE GLOVE BOX.
THOSE SIGNALS ARE DECODED.
AND THEN THEY SEND
VARIOUS SIGNALS
TO ALL THE COMPONENTS
TO CONTROL THE CAR.
TO STEER THE CAR BACK AND FORTH,
BJORN SENDS A SIGNAL
TO THE RECEIVER,
WHICH DRIVES A MOTOR
LOCATED UNDER THE DASHBOARD.
THIS OTHER MOTOR MOVES
THE STEERING WHEEL
AND THEREFORE THE TIRES.
AS YOU CAN SEE,
THIS WHEEL TURNS THE WHEEL.
THIS CONTROL CHANGES THE GEAR.
SO IF BJORN WANTS THE CAR
TO ACCELERATE,
HE SENDS THAT SIGNAL WITH HIS
CONTROLLER TO THE RECEIVER.
THE RECEIVER
THEN TALKS TO THE MOTOR,
WHICH THEN MOVES A LEVER
THAT PUSHES THE ACCELERATOR.
AND OF COURSE, BRAKING.
AND THROTTLE.
[ ENGINE REVVING ]
DUE TO THE SPEED OF THE RADIO
SIGNALS AND THE PROCESSOR,
THERE'S VIRTUALLY NO DELAY.
HOWEVER, A FULL-SIZE CAR
WILL REACT A LOT SLOWER
THAN A TOY CAR EQUIVALENT
BECAUSE OF ITS INCREASED
SIZE AND MASS.
WITH MORE MASS,
IT MEANS IT HAS MORE INERTIA.
AND THAT MEANS
A GREATER RESISTANCE
TO A CHANGE IN MOTION.
Gradman: IN CONTRAST TO HOW
HE WOULD BRAKE
A SMALL REMOTE-CONTROL CAR,
HE HAS TO BRAKE HIS CORVETTE
A LOT EARLIER.
DRIVING IS PRETTY HARD
ON A FULL-SCALE CAR.
YOU'VE GOT TO GET A FEEL
FOR THE BRAKING
AND NOT SLAMMING IT
WITH YOUR FINGER.
SO IN THE END,
BJORN'S BIGGEST LIMITATION
IS HIS OWN REACTION TIME.
BUT BECAUSE OF HIS EPIC
DRIVING SKILLS,
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO PULL THIS OFF.